كلب وشجره واغنيه ما هو سر ابتكارات
ارتيتا في كره القدم
لم ينجح ميكيل ارتيتا في قياده ارسنال
للتتويج بالدوري الانجليزي الممتاز وخسر
السباق امام
ولكنه نال احترام الجميع بعد التغيير
الحقيقي الذي احدثه مع الجناز ارسنال عاد
لدوري ابطال اوروبا وبتهم يمتلك هويه
واضحه وفلسفه واسلوب لعب كل ذلك اضافه
ارتيتا ولكنه لم يفعله فقط من خلال
الافكار والتكتيك بل امتلك اساليب غريبه
بعض الشيء لتكون جزءا من طريقته التدريبيه
تلك الطريقه تعتمد في المقام الاول على
شحن اللاعبين نفسيا وتحفيزهم جنبا الى جنب
مع الخطط والتكتيك وافكار المتطوره كمدرب
صحيفه دايلي ميل افادت ان احدث تعاقدات
ارتيتا كانت صفقه كلبي لابرادور حيث يعتقد
المدير الفني لارسنال ان مداعبه اللاعبين
للكلاب خلال الحصص التدريبيه ست من حده
التوتر وتخلق اجواء من المرح والسعاده مما
يساعد على تحفيزهم اضافه الى ذلك فهو
يتعامل مع الفريق كعائله والعائله تحتاج
الى كلب حتى تكون الاجواء اسريه بين
اللاعبين صفقه الكلب ليست اكثر الاشياء
الغريبه التي استحدثها حيث انه جلب شجره
زيتون عمرها 150 عاما وزرعها خارج مكتبه
لكي تساعد اللاعبين على التحفيز كونها
شجره قويه وتحتاج الكثير من الرعايه وهي
رمزيه تشبه تماما فريق كره القدم خاصه لو
تعلق الامر بناد كبير مثل ارسنال العديد
من افكار ارتيتا تدور حول صناعه اجواء
مماثله للاعبين لذلك فانه قبل مواجهه
ليفربول في انفيلد قام بتشغيل الاغنيه
الشهيره لجماهير الريتز لن تسير وحيدا
ابدا للاعبه في التدريبات حتى يتعود على
اجواء انفيلد قبل مواجهتها في مباراه هامه
المدرب الاسباني يمتلك عاده غريبه اخرى
وهي انه لا ملابسه التي يفوز بها ابدا ولا
يقوم باستبدال ملابسه بالكامل بما فيها
الحذاء سوى في حاله الخساره وفي غرفه
الملابس يعتمد ارتيتا على الرسوم ومحاكاه
سيناريوهات كره القدم من خلال القصص من
اجل تقريب افكاره للاعبين وهو ما ظهر في
الوثائقي الخاص بنادي ارسنالورناث الذي
كشف عن العديد من الاشياء التي تحدث داخل
غرفه النادي المغلقه منذ وصول ارتيتا
ولتطوير افكاره اعتمد ارتيتا على جلسات
محادثه عبر الانترنت ولكنها لم تكن تدور
حول كره القدم بل مع مدربي الرياضات
الاخرى كالركبي وبعض الرياضات الفرديه
وقائد سابق بالجيش الامريكي لكي يحسن
قدراته على التواصل ويتطور كشخص وليس فقط
كمدرب بلا شك اثارت كل هذه الاضافات غير
المالوفه في عالم التدريب كثيرا من الجدل
ورغم ان البعض يتهم المدرب الاسباني
بالمبالغه ومحاوله الاستعراض من خلال هذه
الاشياء الا انها تؤكد على حقيقه امتلاكه
عقليه مخت لفه وهي التي بلا شك قادته لتلك
التطورات السريعه التي جعلتهم مدربا كبيرا
في زمن قياسي